Speaker 1: The floodgates have been opened by
the humiliating endorsement losses last week
for Donald Trump. And now former Vice President
Mike Pence is trashing the very president that
he served under. Mike Pence is now not mincing
words and he is saying Trump was reckless and
he endangered my family. What a brave former vice
president. Right? Sorry, that's me choking on the
absurdity of it. This guy's pathetic. This
guy is pathetic. You had to wait until five
days after the midterm to say what Trump did
was disgusting and he endangered my family,
etc., etc.. No, the time to say it was right
after the January six riots and before the 2022
midterms. And Mike Pence is now taking advantage
of the fact that Trump is as weak as he's been in
a long time and everybody is turning against them.
Not everybody, but many are turning against them
to say the following. Now, it's still notable. He
said this on ABC to David Muir. It's still notable
because I don't remember of any modern historical
example of a vice president and a president
turning on each other. To this degree, it's
emblematic of the dysfunction that always existed
in the Trump White House. Here's Mike Pence.
Speaker 2: Members were barricaded inside the
House chamber. And in the middle of it all,
you can see that the president has tweeted.
2:24 p.m. The President Tweet
Mike Pence didn't have the
courage to do what should have been done.
Speaker 1: And this is a dramatic pause here.
The video hasn't stopped.
Speaker 2:
It angered me. Hmm. But I turn to my daughter.
Speaker 1: Who was standing nearby.
Right. And I said, it doesn't
encourage you break the law.
Takes courage to uphold the law. Mm hmm. I
mean, the president's words were reckless.
It clear he decided to be part of the problem?
Yeah. Mike Pence should have said all of
this before he now found the testicular
fortitude, to use a less crass phrase.
To come out and say this. But why not say it
before the midterms? Dispense feel safe now
because a lot of the Trump backed candidates
failed. It's cowardly to a degree. If you click
now, I know some of you were going to say, oh,
but David, sir, he has a book coming out and it
makes sense to way because he doesn't want to hurt
the Republicans that he likes. Oh, I get why he's
waiting. Trust me, I understand why he's waiting.
But it's cowardly in the sense that if Mike Pence
really wants us to believe he is the patriot
who puts country above all else no matter what.
Then it should be seen as his responsibility to at
the immediate point at which he believes something
as significant as this was a reckless president
I served under who endangered me and my family.
If that is his belief. You don't wait to
strategically time that. That doesn't make
any sense unless your number one guiding
light is actually something different. And
with Pence it is always what is best for
him. Now he's correct. I don't deny that
what Pence is saying is accurate. Trump
was completely reckless on January 6th.
Trump's actions did, and his words did endanger
Pence and his family, where they were, you know,
building a gallows and saying, Hang
Mike Pence. And they still hate Pence.
But Pence is a coward. At the end of the day, and
he should have been saying this six months ago,
he could have been saying this almost two years
ago. Right. 22 months ago when the riots actually
happened. So, Pence, is he setting up his own
run for 2024? We have no idea at this point in
time. But he's saying things that are, of course,
true. But he should have said a long time ago.